mes chers collègues
Madame mes chers collègues nous
poursuivons cet après-midi les travaux
de notre commission d'enquête par
l'audition de Madame Laure le Chartier
directrice de l'accès au marché des
affaires publiques et de la RSE du
laboratoire
UPSA je vous remercie Madame la
Directrice de vous êtes mobilisé pour
cette audition
UPSA constitue un élément historique de
l'industrie pharmaceutique française
puisque cela laboratoire a été fondé en
1935 son ancrage sur un territoire le
Lot-et-Garonne dont il est le premier
employeur privé fait sa force
je salue le sénateur de l'étape beaucoup
de Français le connaissent à travers ces
produits phares que sont l'aspirine et
le Dafalgan efferalgan forme sèche de
paracétamol pas la Spirit bien sûr mais
Dafalgan
qui a connu des difficultés
d'approvisionnement au cours des mois
écoulés vous pourrez donc nous dire
Madame dans quelle mesure le laboratoire
a été confronté à des tensions ruptures
d'approvisionnement
directement ou par accroissement de la
demande liée à des tensions observées
dans d'autres laboratoires et comment il
y a fait face vous pourrez également
nous présenter votre regard sur les
mesures prises mises en oeuvre par le
gouvernement pour lutter contre ces
pénuries notamment s'agissant de la
constitution de stocks et de la
politique de relocalisation de la
production de principes actifs mais
aussi de matières premières pour les
principes actifs
pour le dire autrement cet objectif vous
paraît-il réaliste compte tenu de la
différence de coût de la main d'oeuvre
et des normes environnementales est
liées aux normes environnementales sans
commune mesure entre pays européens et
pays asiatiques doit-elle nécessairement
s'accompagner d'une hausse du prix des
médicaments de certains médicaments je
rappelle qu'il y a quelques jours le
j'aime a demandé une hausse du prix des
MITM de moins de 5 euros
enfin compte tenu de votre activité de
l'international dans quelle mesure
pensez-vous que la question des pénuries
de médicaments peut-elle trouver une
réponse au niveau européen en tant que
producteur vous paraît-il donc envisagea
envisageable par exemple d'harmoniser
les conditionnements pour un même
médicament et j'allais dire les notices
également
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets Madame la
Directrice je vais vous céder la parole
pour un bref propos un productif
j'insiste sur le Bref puis madame
Laurence Cohen rapporte de notre
commission d'enquête vous posera une
première série de questions comme vous
l'aurez compris notre commission
d'enquête en temps obtenir des réponses
étayées à des questions précises je
précise également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite Madame la directrice a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure madame
je vous remercie et vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente alors un
propos liminaire qui sera court vous
dire déjà que comme vous l'avez rappelé
UPSA incarne un ancrage territorial et
la défense d'un savoir-faire qui est le
fabriqué en France et qui rayonne à
l'international car il faut bien avoir
conscience que
UPSA c'est une entreprise de taille
intermédiaire qui fait un chiffre
d'affaires de 436 millions d'euros et
qui finalement va diffuser ces produits
en France c'est le principal marché avec
150 millions de boîtes qui sont donc
distribuées sur le marché français mais
également à l'international avec 100
millions
plus de 100 millions de boîtes qui
seront distribués au niveau
international donc
UPSA cette grande force en fait d'avoir
un ancrage très fort dans le
Lot-et-Garonne à jeun avec deux sites de
production qui sont donc
Guyenne et Gascogne et deux sites de
distribution et qui a cette présence à
la fois en Europe du Nord en Europe du
Sud en Europe de l'Est et centrale et en
Afrique
donc on a véritablement chez UPSA je
dirais une conscience du territoire et
la question qu'on se pose en permanence
c'est
l'enjeu territoriale comment on peut
grandir avec le territoire et comment on
peut faire grandir le territoire et on
se définit souvent comme une entreprise
pollinisatrice puisque vous l'avez
rappelé
on est à l'origine de beaucoup
d'externalités positives l'emploi bien
évidemment puisque on a 1600
collaborateurs chez UPSA mais qu'on
génère aussi un certain nombre d'emplois
indirects qui sont de l'ordre de 3500
donc une vraie responsabilité
territoriale d'entreprise et
UPSA aussi une responsabilité de
garantir une continuité d'accès à nos
médicaments vous rappeliez effectivement
la crise sur le paracétamol qui a eu
lieu donc en 2022 chez
UPSA nous n'avons pas eu de crise et je
pense que là on est justement un cas
illustrant qui montre comment nous avons
fait pour ne pas être dans cette
difficulté d'approvisionnement nous
n'avons pas eu de rupture
d'approvisionnement et nous avons été en
capacité et bien de répondre à la
demande des patients adultes et pour
l'enfant j'y reviendrai nous avons
également essayé de pallier les
insuffisances qu'il y avait sur le
marché puisque nous sommes présents sur
le marché adulte nous sommes en revanche
très peu présent sur le marché de
l'enfant
donc
nos enjeux aujourd'hui chez UPSA c'est
vraiment l'enjeu du fabricant France du
maintien des sites industriels en France
de la façon aussi de collaborer sur un
territoire avec l'ensemble de
l'écosystème pour faire vivre une
entreprise pour garder une attractivité
et finalement une industrie qui est
performante sur son territoire c'est une
industrie qui va à la fois innover et
chez nous nous innovons sur tous les
process technologiques mais c'est aussi
de pouvoir avoir des talents de pouvoir
former de pouvoir
recruter sur le territoire
et ses pouvoirs aussi garantir une
autonomie stratégique et je pense que
UPSA garantit cette autonomie
stratégique à la France et ajustement
une capacité de production stratégique
pour la France qu'elle a démontré lors
de la crise
récente puisque nous avons été en
première ligne mais encore une fois nous
n'avons pas eu ces ruptures
d'approvisionnement et je pourrais
revenir sur les causes et pourquoi nous
n'avons pas eu ces ruptures notre grande
force c'est justement cette agilité au
niveau de la production puisqu'on est
capable d'organiser nos cycles de
production
de façon très rapide de les modifier en
fonction de la demande c'est également
notre source
d'approvisionnement puisque sur le
paracétamol nous nous approvisionnions
essentiellement aux États-Unis et en
Chine
donc on avait cette capacité d'avoir
65% de notre approvisionnement aux
États-Unis on a également notre force
sont les hommes et les femmes du PSA qui
sont des collaborateurs particulièrement
engagés qui ont le trèfle au cœur parce
que UPSA c'est une histoire humaine
avant tout je vous disais c'est une ETI
on est vraiment à une échelle voilà très
intermédiaire dans le paysage
pharmaceutique et ce sont des hommes et
des femmes engagés qui se sont mobilisés
24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 et qui
ont permis justement et bien de garantir
aux patients une continuité d'accès à
ces médicaments ce médicament vous
citiez Dafalgan efferalgan effectivement
nous avons deux des trois les marques
les plus connues en France sur le marché
et de garantir cette continuité d'accès
pour un médicament qui reste essentiel
car là aussi c'est un point important le
paracétamol c'est une molécule certes
ancienne qu'on parle qu'on qualifie
souvent de médicaments matures mais
c'est pas parce que c'est un médicament
mature que c'est un médicament de
seconde zone c'est un médicament et
l'OMS le dit essentiel et la crise covid
l'a bien prouvé en mettant aussi en
exergue délumérabilités sur la
production du principe actif
donc pour répondre à votre question sur
la question de de la relocalisation
puisque vous voyez que chez nous notre
ADN c'est vraiment le fabriquer en
France
on y tient on y croit on le démontre
chaque jour et c'est pourquoi suite à la
crise covid et bien on s'est engagé très
activement dans le projet de
relocalisation qui a été porté par le
Président de la République et qui est
porté également par France relance on
s'est engagé donc aux côtés du chimiste
séquence pour justement
œuvrer à la relocalisation de ce
principe actif en France et remonter
d'un cran dans la chaîne de valeur
puisque vous l'avez bien compris nous
nous produisons nos médicaments donc à
jeun à partir du moment où on reçoit le
principe actif paracétamol
mais que se pose la question de remonter
d'un cran dans cette chaîne de valeur
pour gagner en autonomie et en
indépendance sanitaire et c'est pourquoi
ce projet qui nous semble tout à fait
hématiques à recueilli notre total
adhésion et nous y investissons
nous y investissons voilà des moyens
extrêmement importants puisque nous
participons à la mise en service de
cette unité
et nous nous engageons également sur des
volumes jusqu'en 2029
et donc si vous voulez cela répond à une
véritable préoccupation chez nous aussi
qui est de dire qu'il faut sécuriser
bien évidemment l'approvisionnement
principe actif et qu'il faut essayer de
le sécuriser en
œuvrant aussi pour une je dirais une
filière intégrée qui soit environnement
environnement
à main d'un point de vue en
environnemental responsable pardon et
c'est un point important parce que ça
participe aussi de notre démarche
de Responsabilité Sociétale d'entreprise
donc oui on est parti prenante on est un
acteur clé de ce projet de
relocalisation et on pense que c'est une
réponse importante à la question de la
vulnérabilité aujourd'hui au niveau des
médicaments
et pour pour clore et après je vous
laisserai
voilà poser toutes les questions
bien évidemment le corollaire de cette
relocalisation de principes actif en
France c'est en tout cas une visibilité
un peu meilleure sur les prix et sur la
stabilité des prix puisque et je pense
que on vous l'a souvent dit aujourd'hui
la politique de prix sur les médicaments
matures c'est une politique de tassement
de prix donc au fil des années c'est à
dire c'est une logique extrêmement
comptable qui vise à dire que on va
réduire le prix de ces médicaments qui
sont anciens pour justement financer
l'innovation donc c'est ça c'est le
raisonnement actuel on voit bien que ce
raisonnement il est à bout de souffle il
atteint ses limites puisque
ces molécules matures
et bien on en a besoin et que justement
avec ce type de raisonnement ça a pu
conduire à la délocalisation de la
production des principes actifs hors de
France donc à partir du moment on va
réinternaliser les principes en France
il est sûr que les coûts de production
et bien vont être impactées et qu'il
faut que les conditions économiques
soient viables du coup pour les
fabricants de médicaments tels que ça et
que sur un prix de paracétamol alors je
vous donne juste un exemple le prix
d'une boîte de paracétamol prix
fabricant hors taxes aujourd'hui c'est
76 centimes
c'est à dire que nous l'avons donc 76
centimes
donc on voit bien qu'on est quasiment à
l'os et que ce serait pas raisonnable de
baisser encore plus le prix de ce prix
fabricant hors taxes et par conséquent à
partir du moment on va s'approvisionner
en France il serait légitime de
répercuter en tout cas sur le prix
fabricant et bien le coût supplémentaire
de cette matière première
donc nous nous appelons en tout cas une
politique de prix qui soit juste
pour laquelle on est de la visibilité et
qui reconnaît ceci la place des produits
nature c'est-à-dire qu'on a fait
beaucoup pour les médicaments innovants
avec une politique qui a permis de
faciliter l'accès on a fait beaucoup
pour la politique des génériques mais on
voit bien aujourd'hui qu'il y a une
troisième voie avec la politique des
produits matures qui sont des produits
où on pourrait revaloriser leurs prix en
repensant
leur valeur qui est réelle pour la santé
des Français
merci beaucoup je passe la parole à
Laurence Cohen rapporteur
oui merci Madame le Chartier pour vos
propos très très clairs et très
synthétiques donc vous avez dit que vous
n'aviez pas vécu de rupture
d'approvisionnement j'ai bien j'ai bien
entendu mais en fait est-ce que vous
avez été confronté à un accroissement
inattendu on va dire de la demande
contenue je parle de certains
médicaments justement en raison de
tension ou de rupture chez un certain
nombre de vos de vos concurrents ça
c'est ma première question la deuxième
question c'est peut-être
approfondir un petit peu les pistes que
vous avez ouvertes concernant la
sécurisation de vos chaînes
d'approvisionnement
j'ai bien entendu que vous étiez enfin
vos équipes étaient vraiment sur le pont
7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24
donc
je voulais je voulais savoir si
justement cette cette mobilisation
a permis de créer de nouvelles de
nouveaux emplois pour justement
permettre aussi une meilleure de
meilleures conditions de travail pour
tout un pour tout un chacun
ça c'est donc ma deuxième question ma
troisième question c'est l'existence de
short liner c'est d'exportation
parallèle est-ce que ça vous paraît un
vrai problème puisque c'est
effectivement c'est ce qui apparaît
comme étant un vrai problème mais en
tout cas quel est votre votre analyse et
dans quelle mesure vous-même vous êtes
affecté par par ce phénomène
ensuite nous vous avez parlé de la
fixation des des prix des médicaments
nous avons au niveau de nos auditions
beaucoup entendus et
partageons le fait que le prix des
médicaments et
Pâques c'est à dire qu'il y a pas du
tout de transparence sur le prix des
médicaments là vous nous avez donné en
fait ce que coûte une boîte de
paracétamol mais en réalité
il nous semblerait intéressant pour le
pour le public pour tout un chacun dans
le fait de mieux mesurer que
la fixation de ce prix du médicament
prend en compte les normes
environnementales et
social parce que s'il y a eu des
localisations en fait il y a eu
délocalisation par rapport à ce que vous
avez dit mais aussi parce que c'était
plus pratique
n'est pas le mot exact mais plus
confortable d'aller dans des pays où les
normes
environnementales et sociales et témoins
exigeantes donc si des entreprises font
l'effort de relocaliser en France il
faut pas qu'elle soit après en
concurrence avec des produits qui sont
qui sont ailleurs et dont les normes
sont moins exigeantes donc ces normes là
devant rentrer en ligne de compte le
service rendu bien évidemment en termes
en termes médicales
la comment dirais la réelle part de ce
que coûte enfin le coût réel de la
production et enfin la marge tout à fait
normal le bénéfice qui doit qui peut
être tiré par par l'entreprise puisque
chaque peine mérite salaire quoi donc
voilà mais que tout ça soit transparent
et ce qui rendrait d'ailleurs confiance
je pense à nos concitoyens et à nos
concitoyens donc qu'est-ce qu'elle
regarde vous vous portez au niveau de
cette notion de transparence des prix
des médicaments
vous avez sur la les politiques de
régulation des dépenses du médicament
toujours en France on nous a parlé dans
un certain nombre de nos
auditions de la clause de sauvegarde qui
prend une place de plus en plus
importante et qui suivent nos
interlocuteurs et critiquer pour
notamment son caractère indifférencier
donc quel est votre regard et comment
par rapport à ça y compris vous vous
pensez vous jugez pouvoir faire évoluer
ce
système sans qu'il puisse y avoir une
explosion des dépenses qui qui seraient
incontrôlées
enfin quels sont selon vous
les conditions à mettre en place pour
instituer vraiment la souveraineté
sanitaire vous en avez un petit peu
parlé mais peut-être en approfondissant
les pistes que vous avez que vous avez
ouvertes par exemple quand vous nous
dites que vous vous investissez au
niveau du du projet de relocalisation
notamment sur les principes actifs nous
avons eu l'occasion donc avec la
présidente d'aller sur le site de rohapi
c'était une expérience d'ailleurs
extrêmement intéressante
mais donc est-ce que vous vous pouvez
nous dire quelle est la la teneur de
votre projet et à quel moment vous
pensez qu'il va être opérationnel
c'est-à-dire combien de temps nous
pourrons dans combien de temps nous
pourrons au niveau de la France en
bénéficier et
voilà j'ai abordé les questions qui me
semblaient principales et après l'école
alors pas je me suis heureusement que
j'ai non mais il y avait aussi euro
happy qui avait donc le principe actif
et il y a aussi séquences qui
s'engage sur une une unité de production
voilà pour être tout à fait complète les
deux donc la parole est à vous enfin la
présidente qui va vous la donner ou pas
donc à vous madame diatrice pour une
réponse à ces premières questions tout à
fait merci Madame la rapporteur alors
pour pour votre première question
concernant l'accroissement de la demande
effectivement nous avons nous-même
observé une augmentation de cette
demande parce que comme vous le savez il
y avait aussi une situation
épidémiologique avec une triple épidémie
à la fois covid
grippe et bronchiolite qui a conduit à
une augmentation de la demande des
patients et si vous reprenez nos
chiffres sur l'année donc 2022 nous
avons produit à peu près 350 millions de
boîtes sur notre usine d'Agen donc une
augmentation
significative au regard de l'année 2021
donc accroissement de la demande mais
capacités encore une fois à y répondre
parce que
[Musique]
1500 collaborateurs on a également
recruté bien évidemment puisque si vous
voulez on est aujourd'hui dans un moment
assez décisif de notre histoire on est
dans une
dans un plan de transformation
stratégique donc on se développe
beaucoup et se développements il doit
aussi pouvoir servir je dirais l'emploi
sur le territoire donc on a également
recruté
on est également face à toutes les
difficultés que connaissent les
entreprises aujourd'hui sur les
difficultés de recrutement et des
métiers qui peuvent être aussi en
tension donc ça ça peut aussi nous
toucher donc on a un certain nombre de
postes qui sont toujours vers ou
recrutement mais on est bien dans cette
dynamique là et cette cette croissance
nous permet aussi et bien d'avoir
plus d'emplois sur le site
concernant votre question sur les short
liners nous ne sommes pas du tout
concernés en fait par cette question
donc on n'a pas
voilà on n'a pas on n'est pas impacté
par ce type de de préoccupation
sur la question de la fixation des prix
de médicaments vous vous qualifiez ce
processus d'OPAC
alors ce processus en fait on connaît
les règles parce que les règles elles
sont quand même assez précises et dictée
de façon précise dans un accord cadre
aussi entre le lait et le CEPS
sur les produits matures ce que je vous
disais c'est à dire que ce sont des
réflexes finalement très comptables de
dire quel est l'ancienneté de la
molécule depuis quand le prix est stable
voilà donc avec une logique de baisse de
prix tassement pris au fil des années et
ça ça semble assez délétère je dirais
puisque finalement
ces produits matures ils ont une vraie
fonction en santé et conserve un service
médical rendu important si je prends le
cas de spécialités Dafalgan et feralgan
elles ont toujours une place dans la
stratégie thérapeutique elle rentre
toujours un service important au patient
sur la qualité de vie des passions qui
soient chronique ou aiguë et ça reste
quand même des molécules essentielles
donc on voit bien que cette logique de
raisonnement elle ne tient pas surtout
si on veut maintenir sur le territoire
français
et bien des des sites de production
parce que des sites de production c'est
des savoir-faire technologiques c'est
aussi et bien des investissements pour
être toujours à la pointe de la
technologie
et ces investissements là bien il y a il
y a un moment il se répercute forcément
dans le coup de production donc je à ce
que vous dites sur le fait que la
tarification du médicament elle ne doit
pas se limiter à cette approche
comptable
d'ancienneté d'une molécule
qu'il a discrédite en plus dans la
pharmacopée alors qu'en fait elle a une
place réelle et une valeur en santé et
qu'on devrait dans la tarification
prendre en compte d'autres critères il y
avait eu l'empreinte territoriale que
vous-même vous aviez voté pour la LFSS
mais vous avez fait comme nous le
constat que ça a été très long
la mise en oeuvre de cette disposition
que nous nous trouvions excellente et
Gérard Larcher est venu sur notre site
UPSA en à l'automne dernier et on a pu
lui faire part justement de cette
difficulté de non exécution d'une
disposition législative donc
heureusement
les choses sont débloqués cette année et
l'empreinte territoriale va être prise
en compte dans la tarification mais
reste quand même à savoir précisément
les critères qui vont être pris en
compte donc oui bien évidemment toutes
ces externalités positives d'une
entreprise sur son territoire devrait se
refléter dans le prix et vous abordez
aussi une question qui nous est très
chère nous chez UPSA qui est la question
de la responsabilité sociétale
d'entreprise ou à partir du moment où
une entreprise fait un effort
particulier au niveau environnemental et
bien cet effort devrait être aussi
valorisé dans le prix
du médicament donc ça devrait aussi être
un critère à prendre en compte et
typiquement voyez chez nous chez UPSA on
a mis en place un pacte durable
qui justement a un engagement très fort
sur
et bien notre site avec un plan de
décarbonation et une neutralité carbone
sur nos émissions directes à l'horizon
2027 mais également sur nos produits
avec une exigence évidemment de de
possibilités de recyclage et des
conception des produits
donc oui que c'est j'irai ses efforts
d'entreprise vertueux sur un territoire
soit pris en compte dans le prix me
semblerait assez logique et en tout cas
ça participerait d'un cercle vertueux
parce que ça permet après et bien
d'entretenir cette dynamique en fait sur
un territoire
de recrutement de croissance de
développement d'une entreprise
sur votre question concernant les
politiques de régulation et là on est
plus sur un point de fiscalité avec la
clause de sauvegarde effectivement
très très honnêtement
nous nous pensons que cette clause de
sauvegarde en fait c'est une fiscalité
confiscatoire
et pourquoi parce que
et bien parce que justement avec nos
produits à base de paracétamol Dafalgan
efferalgan nous sommes dans la catégorie
des produits nature
et que
nous ne sommes pas
directement responsables du dépassement
en fait du montant qui est voté
annuellement par le Parlement pour les
dépenses en matière de médicaments
remboursables
toutefois nous sommes impactés par la
mutualisation et le reverversement
finalement de se dépassement donc
nous considérons que en tant que produit
mature nous sommes pénalisés par ce
mécanisme de la clause de sauvegarde
et que c'est une pénalité qui est
importante puisque par exemple nous chez
hubson elle a été multipliée par 10
donc voyez que l'impact il est quand
même extrêmement fort donc une fiscalité
confiscatoire à laquelle on pourrait
donner une autre réponse si on veut
s'inscrire dans cette logique de la
souveraineté industrielle du
développement de l'outil industriel sur
un territoire on pourrait très bien
imaginer une clause de sauvegarde qui ne
s'appuie pas que sur le chiffre
d'affaires de l'entreprise
bon la croissance effectivement est un
deuxième paramètre qui a été introduit
mais on pourrait très bien penser à un
paramètre qui est la production locale
et qu'à partir du moment où les
entreprises produisent localement et
bien elle pourrait être exonérée d'une
partie de cette clause de sauvegarde ce
qui permet de servir complètement les
intérêts politiques aujourd'hui en
matière de reconquête industrielle et de
souveraineté sanitaire cette proposition
là je sais que elle a été
discutée l'année dernière dans le cadre
de la plfs
pour 2023 voilà et donc c'est une
proposition en tout cas
qui permet de s'inscrire dans cette
logique de de la reconquête industrielle
donc voilà ma réponse pour la clause de
sauvegarde puisque en fait la conclusion
c'est quand même que nous devrions tous
être égaux devant l'impôt et que
finalement nous ne sommes pas égaux là
devant cette impola puisque
il est mutualisé ne prend pas en compte
je dirais les tendances
inhérentes à chaque laboratoire
alors pour votre dernière question sur
la souveraineté sanitaire et la question
de la relocalisation oui comme je vous
disais nous nous sommes très engagés
dans ce projet de relocalisation
nous pensons que c'est une réponse très
utile finalement
à l'autonomie stratégique
et c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs on est
dans cette logique d'avoir un des
sources d'approvisionnement en circuit
court parce que je pense qu'aussi
quand on est dans une logique de
développement durable il faut pouvoir
s'approvisionner en circuit court or là
typiquement ce projet de relocalisation
du paracétamol nous offre la possibilité
de nous approvisionner en circuit court
avec une filière intégrée et qui
respecte l'environnement puisque il y a
beaucoup de choses et si vous avez
visité vous dire beaucoup de choses qui
ont été faites justement pour que ce
process de production soit très
respectueux de l'environnement donc
ce sont des initiatives qui doivent être
développées après ce dont il faut avoir
conscience c'est que la relocalisation
c'est un temps long c'est qu'on ne peut
pas relocaliser du jour au lendemain
voyez que le projet a commencé en 2021
qu'on aura un premier paracétamol
français en 2025 donc il y a un temps
long qui un temps déjà de réhabilitation
là en conséquence de désinstallations et
ensuite
on doit aussi bien requalifier la le
principe actif etc donc
il faut voilà il faut s'inscrire dans ce
temps qui est long mais c'est tout à
fait possible je pense qu'avec des
acteurs engagés avec des moyens
et bien on peut on peut collectivement
y réussir
très bien merci beaucoup pour pour ces
réponses je sais pas si
des questions complètementaires donc je
vais passer la parole pour une seconde
série de questions
une fois que le nom sera écrit
vous allez pouvoir
donc voilà c'est bon donc Corinne Imbert
d'abord
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
pour vos propos
j'ai plusieurs petites questions dans
l'histoire du PSA est-ce que au début de
son histoire la production de
paracétamol était dans vos usines déjà
et que vous avez délocalisé ou est-ce
que depuis toujours vous avez acheté le
principe actif aux États-Unis ou en
Chine
[Musique]
vous avez évoqué le prix pharmacien le
prix fabricant pardon hors taxes d'une
boîte de Dafalgan paracétamol
quel est son prix de revient si vous
pouvez nous le donner est-ce que
le prix de revient et le même pour une
boîte de gélules pour une boîte de
comprimés secs pour une boîte de
comprimés effervescent puisque
historiquement le savoir-faire du PSA
c'était l'effervescence c'était la haute
qualité de l'effervescence et on parlait
pas d'un comprimé d'aspirine et
donne-moi un nubsa voilà c'était reconnu
pour la qualité de l'effervescence sans
résidu donc à savoir-faire certes cette
technologie date évidemment mais est-ce
que le prix aujourd'hui de revient pour
le laboratoire de ces trois formes
galéniques et identiques ou pas et
est-ce que le prix
de remboursement
mériterait que la forme galénique soit
mieux prise en compte ou pas
puisque vous parlez de la revalorisation
des produits nature est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui selon vous il est il est
normal en terre que et bien quel que
soit la présentation le prix de
remboursement par l'assurance maladie
est le même
et une autre question si vous le
permettez comment avez-vous vécu le
contingentement qui vous a été imposé
vous nous avez dit nous n'avons pas été
en rupture d'approvisionnement nous
avons eu des demandes qui ont augmenté
nous avons été agis nous avons pu
augmenter notre production donc nous
n'étions pas en situation de rupture
d'approvisionnement or comme l'autre
principale laboratoire concurrent enfin
voilà
que nous connaissons qui a été au déjà
auditionné par cette commission
d'enquête il vous a été imposé le même
contingentement
comment l'avez-vous vécu voilà pour
l'instant je vous remercie
Laurence haribet
merci madame la Présidente vous parlez
donc de d'une priorité pour vous et d'un
ADN qui est de l'ancrage territorial
est-ce que vous avez eu des
financements publics pour accompagner
cette territorialisation
qu'est-ce que ça représente exactement
et est-ce qu'à votre avis il faut en
tenir compte dans l'évaluation du prix
et en tout cas dans le dans l'évaluation
du modèle économique merci
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
pour vous expliquer alors dans le même
sens vous avez parlé tout à l'heure donc
de cet investissement
prochain auquel vous prenez pas donc
l'intérêt serait de savoir à quel
montant il s'élève et quel le montant
donc de votre entreprise et le montant
de de l'investissement public
vous parlez de circuits courts de
relocalisation d'entreprise humaine
d'emploi donc ce sont des termes qui en
politique nous parlent beaucoup bien sûr
parce que
c'est c'est un peu le monde idéal que
nous aimerions connaître or on sait bien
que vous êtes quand même dans dans un
une branche très concurrentielle et
est-ce que tous ces arguments là et
cette position là elle arrive quand même
à sauver l'entreprise
vous parlez de circuit court et de la
localisation mais est-ce que ça va
pouvoir vous garantir l'achat chez vous
cette relocalisation est-ce que vous
avez un engagement pour cela parce que
la concurrence est rude et aujourd'hui
vous êtes petit par rapport au grand Big
Pharma ils peuvent vous mettre des
bâtons dans les roues
peuvent
ils sont lobbistes ne l'êtes-vous pas
est-ce que vous avez vos entrées à
Bruxelles etc puisque aujourd'hui on vit
quand même dans ce monde là et si vous
pouviez nous en parler merci
Jean-Pierre Moga merci Madame le
présidente moi je voulais vous parler en
premier vous demandez pourquoi vous
n'aviez pas connu la pénurie mais je
crois que c'est pas la peine que je pose
ma question vous avez répondu par par
contre par rapport à ça ma collègue à
côté un peu évoqué la question c'est
celui des coûts de production parce que
de temps en temps je viens chez vous je
suis même venu une nuit voir les les
équipes de nuit comment ça se passait et
j'ai vu qu'effectivement vous étiez
passé d'un système à 28 ou à 3,8 à des
systèmes à une organisation où on
travaille le dimanche et tout et moi qui
viens de l'industrie quand on travaille
le dimanche on a les coûts de production
forcément qui augmentent parce que les
salaires et c'est tout à fait normal
sont pas les mêmes le dimanche depuis je
me suis rendu compte qu'au niveau du du
management et du personnel je suis passé
vers 2h du matin dans la salle de
restaurant de du personnel du PSA et
j'ai demandé il y avait des gens ça vous
surprendra pas qu'à Lot-et-Garonne on
mange du confit du canard mais qui était
en train de manger à 2h du matin leur
confit de canard je voudrais savoir
c'est bon il me dit vous savez dans
cette entreprise on a beaucoup de chance
parce que la nuit on a une cuisinier qui
nous fait des plats chauds donc ça aussi
je pense que ça vous coûte on est allé
visiter ensemble d'autres entreprises
vous avez vu que il y a le placard où
les gens amènent ça se fait dans toutes
les industries ce qu'on appelle la
gamelle ils mettent dans le frigo et
puis après dans la salle de restaurant
il mange chez ça c'est bon tout ça ça a
un coût vous avez dû je suppose puisque
vous travaillez le dimanche et tout et
est-ce que vous pourriez nous parler
parce que le prix restait fixé vous
touchez toujours la même somme pour la
boîte de comprimé soit fabriqué la nuit
du dimanche au lundi ou de samedi au
dimanche nous donner des précisions de
ma collègue le demander sur vos coups de
production qui ont augmenté sans que vos
revenus augmentent puisque et je pense
que c'est quelque chose d'importantes
parce que ça peut montrer aussi que
votre votre staff vos actionnaires ont
accepté peut-être d'avoir je ne sais pas
vous allez le dire moins de
de bénéfices ensuite j'avais une autre
question puisque je suis Lot-et-Garonne
je me suis aperçu que vous aviez une une
communication alors je sais pas si on
vous l'a demandé ou quoi beaucoup plus
importantes pendant la crise et beaucoup
de prise de parole alors je sais pas si
c'est une volonté de votre entreprise si
c'était pour pouvoir peut-être recruter
de personnages n'en sais rien est-ce que
il y a une une raison est-ce que c'est
une de vos volonté lorsque c'est les
médias qui sont venus vers vous pour
vous demander de de prendre la parole
plus souvent que ce soit la radio ou
voilà télévision et enfin dernière j'ai
été un peu longue dernière question sur
certains médicaments vous vous enduisez
2% 3% vous avez multiplié votre
production par deux je suppose que si
vous en avez fait 15% ou 20%, vous
auriez peut-être pu aussi multiplier par
deux ça aurait changé la donne tout le
monde n'a pas pu apparemment le faire
est-ce que vous pensez pas qu'au niveau
national on devrait avoir sur les
médicaments par rapport aux entreprises
que l'on a locales je pense à celle
qu'on a aussi
pas loin de chez nous que ce soit
Castres ou à Toulouse ou ailleurs
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il l'État devrait
pas veiller à une meilleure répartition
des volumes pour qu'en cas de crise que
l'on a connu mais on est certainement
moins de problèmes et comme on dit à la
campagne chez nous ne pas avoir les yeux
dans le même panier je vous remercie
de façon courte la parole
moi je rebondis sur les formes
galéniques aussi sur la question des
formes pédiatriques qu'est-ce qui
justifie finalement hormis évidemment la
question des sirops avec le flaconnage
quand on voit bien que c'est un mode de
fabrication différent qu'est-ce qui est
justifie qu'on est une rareté des formes
des formes pédiatriques
et donc c'est un peu la même question
c'est est-ce que ça coûte plus cher ou
parce qu'il y a moins de commandes moins
de consommation et donc moins de lignes
de fabrication finalement voilà et ma
deuxième question porte sur sur la
question des relocalisations parce qu'on
parle de relocalisation mais la chaîne
de valeur de fabrication du médicament
ça va de de la chimie avec même les
matières premières comme comme séquence
en amont du principe actif jusqu'au
jusqu'au conditionnement secondaires et
est-ce que relocaliser pour vous quand
vous évoqué cette question vous
n'évoquez que la question de la chimie
parce que c'est un vrai sujet parce que
on a l'impression que le façonnage on y
arrive le conditionnement on y arrive et
que c'est vraiment la question de la
chimie qui finalement est le maillon
faible de la relocalisation et la pierre
d'achoppement sur la question des
pénuries c'est à dire et est-ce que vous
pensez alors là ça déborde du cadre de
votre entreprise mais je pense que par
votre parcours vous avez une
connaissance plus assez vaste
en fonction des molécules enfin des des
matières premières un certain nombre ne
peuvent pas être fournis ou fabriqués
sur le sol français pour des raisons
d'origine enfin d'extraction par exemple
et comment comment vous vous imaginez
que cette carence peut être palier
voilà pour pour répondre aux pénuries
mais vraiment la question de la
relocalisation c'est est-ce que parce
qu'on remet une usine de fabrication de
boîte
tu remplissage de boîte on considère
qu'on a relocalisé
et puis Laurence oui juste dans le
prolongement y compris au niveau de la
commission d'enquête on pense pas qu'il
faille tout relocaliser en France ce
serait pas du tout réaliste il y a une
coordination à obtenir au niveau
européen pour que voilà les productions
les fabrications etc se situent dans la
proximité
localement évidemment mais aussi au
niveau européen et comme nous sommes
dans une commission d'enquête je veux
rectifier ce que j'ai dit au début de
mon propos en fait quand on parle de
paracétamol c'est pas euroapie c'est
séquence voilà donc je préfère être
précise pour ne pas en plus moi en tant
que rapporteur dire quelque chose qui
n'était pas exact voilà ce qui est fait
merci beaucoup vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente j'avais bien
compris que c'était séquence
alors pour répondre à votre question sur
l'histoire du PSA donc ça déjà existe
depuis 87 ans donc voyez c'est une
entreprise qui est très ancienne et dont
l'histoire a commencé justement dans le
Lot-et-Garonne à Agen et qui s'est
internetisé
bien évidemment
nous n'avons jamais produit de
paracétamol sur nos sites industriels il
faut bien comprendre que la production
de principes actifs c'est un métier qui
est de la chimie et que nous ne pouvons
pas internaliser ce métier nous nous
sommes des entreprises pharmaceutiques
donc raison pour laquelle on
s'approvisionnait auprès de Rodia et qui
a quitté la France en 2008 compte tenu
et bien de de la politique de prix qui
existait à l'époque
concernant notre prix fabricant hors
taxes donc qui est de 76 centimes
alors je veux juste attirer votre
attention sur ce point parce que si vous
allez dans une officie
vous allez acheter votre paracétamol
enfin votre
Dafalgan et feralgan 2 euros 18 donc il
faut bien voir que là on est sur la
rémunération de l'industriel sur un prix
total donc il y a 76 centimes et
qu'après vous avez une marge grossiste
une marge pharmacien un peu de TVA et
également les honoraires dispensation du
pharmacien qui sont là pour rémunérer un
acte pharmaceutique du pharmacien donc
c'est pour vous montrer la part que ça
représente dans le prix final du
paracétamol concernant notre
prix de revient notre prix de revient
comment on le calcule on calcule et bien
en prenant le coût des matières
premières le coût des matériaux de
conditionnement aux on ajoute ce qu'on
appelle les coûts de conversion
c'est-à-dire la main d'oeuvre tout ce
qui est la dépréciation aussi de nos
installations et du fonctionnement de
nos infrastructures donc ça ça fait
notre prix de revient
mais si je dois
vous dire en fait sur sur la rentabilité
aujourd'hui de nos produits
très clairement enfin
ce sont des produits qui qui n'ont pas
un seuil de rentabilité qui est très
élevé preuve en est que notamment sur
la pédiatrie que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure on n'est même plutôt
un seuil de rentabilité qui est négatif
sur les solutions pédiatriques
concernant votre question sur le
contingentement alors nous on a toujours
encouragé un dialogue très ouvert bien
évidemment avec la NSM avec les
différents cabinets ministériels sur la
situation que l'on a tous connu sur le
paracétamol adulte et j'en conviens sur
l'enfant il y a eu
un vrai souci
mais je dirais que nous de se
contententement bon on a beaucoup
communiqué auprès de la NSM sur l'état
de nos stocks en officine mais également
dans nos usines donc en montrant que on
avait la capacité de répondre à la
demande en tout cas en ce qui concernait
les formes adultes après on s'est
conformé aux décisions de la NSM voilà
qui prend aussi ses décisions dans un
but je dirais de protection de la santé
publique
et à noter aussi que sur les formes
pédiatriques puisque c'est une question
qui est abordée aussi après
nous nous pouvions pas pallier les
insuffisances qui existaient sur le
marché puisque je vous ai expliqué on a
à peu près 5% du marché
on nous aurait demandé on a déjà doublé
un autre capacité de production sur la
pédiatrie donc ce qui est quand même
énorme puisque et en fait ce qu'on a
fait et ce qu'on a proposé à la NSM et
au cabinet de Roland Lescure c'est de
réorienter une partie des doses
pédiatriques qui étaient destinées à
l'export pour le marché français et donc
on a réorienté un million de doses qui
étaient destinés à l'export pour la
France et on l'a fait si vous voulez
dans un geste totalement
responsable
et je dirais pour l'intérêt général
parce que sur le marché français on vend
à perte nos solutions pédiatriques
alors qu'elle export et bien là
nos ventes sont rentables
et ça ça a été possible parce qu'aussi
la NSM nous a permis de le faire puisque
vous savez quand on produit pour un pays
étranger c'est avec des
[Musique]
je dirais des exigences spécifiques
puisqu'on disait tout à l'heure notice
etc donc là on a pu justement
réorienter sur le marché français avec
une autorisation de la NSM donc on a
aussi très bien travaillé avec la NSM
sur ce sujet là pour le bien des enfants
sur la question de l'encrage territorial
et si on bénéficie de financement public
alors
en fait il y a plein de possibilités de
financement public sur je dirais
aujourd'hui sur la modernisation de nos
outils industriels sur la décarbonation
aussi de notre outil industriel
notamment via France 2030
pour l'instant nous n'en bénéficions pas
encore de ce type de subvention mais je
pense que ce type de finances enfin à ce
type de subvention en tout cas oui
permet quand même d'aider le maintien
des sites industriels donc à une réelle
utilité en tout cas incitative
et d'aménagement du territoire donc je
pense que ce sont de très bonnes
dispositions et en tout cas qui
permettent d'être dans cette logique
de continuer à développer l'outil
industriel ce que nous chez UPSA notre
souci c'est ça c'est de se dire il faut
qu'on continue à pouvoir développer ce
soutien industriel pour développer
développer l'emploi sur le territoire
alors après sur la question de
l'investissement
et de notre montant d'investissement
dans le projet de relocalisation donc
avec le chimiste séquent effectivement
c'est un projet France relance
alors
moi je peux pas c'est un peu compliqué
compte tenu des des différentes parties
prenantes qui sont sur ce projet de dire
quelle est notre investissement mais
c'est investissement qui est
tout à fait significatif et comme je
vous le disais c'est à la fois pour
contribuer à la remise en installation
de cette chaîne de production mais
également pour s'engager sur des volumes
parce qu'à partir du moment on a
reconstruit un outil de production il
faut être capable et bien de d'avoir
justement
des volumes
et donc c'est c'est
l'engagement qu'on a aujourd'hui
pour pour avoir du paracétamol français
d'ici 2025
concernant la question sur nous
UPSA
c'est vrai nous sommes une ti donc
vraiment dans le paysage tirait des
entreprises
voilà on a une singularité
donc une ti
on est une entreprise humaine en tout
cas on a un credo qui est de tout de
placer l'humain au cœur de toutes nos
actions parce qu'on pense que le
bien-être et la qualité de vie de nos
collaborateurs c'est une dimension de la
réussite en fait de l'entreprise donc on
est très
centré sur ce bien-être et qualité de
vie des collaborateurs parce qu'on sait
que des collaborateurs mobilisés
et bien c'est ça qui permet aussi
d'obtenir de la performance et on l'a
démontré pendant la crise qu'on a eu
c'est à dire que nos
collaborateurs mobilisés ont permis de
produire plus de 350 millions de boîtes
sur les deux sites de reviennent et
d'Agen et après
on pense que si vous voulez parce que on
fait du fabriqué en France que ça c'est
une force extrêmement importante
aujourd'hui que c'est un levier de
différenciation de pouvoir prouver que
la quasi-totalité de nos produits sont
fabriqués en France et d'être dans cette
démarche de développement durable avec
des ambitions chiffrées
et un processus de certification que
l'on souhaite aussi vers une
certification bitcorp
donc après c'est réussir à convaincre
justement sur le fait que on est là et
que on a cette ces externalités
extrêmement positives pour la France et
qu'on a cette capacité aussi de rayonner
au niveau international
pour la question concernant les les
coûts de production parce que je vais
pas y revenir parce que je pense que
j'ai beaucoup parlé de ces coups de
production du prix de revient bien
évidemment les coûts de production
ont tendance à augmenter et je vous
cache pas que avec les années qu'on
vient de traverser 2022-2023 il y a eu
aussi une très forte inflation puisque
nous on a eu 36% sur le paracétamol on a
eu 20% sur les plastiques 19% sur les
cartons l'aluminium donc vous voyez que
il y a cette inflex inflation qui a été
un véritable choc mais que l'on a
absolument pas pu répercuter sur nos
prix puisque nos prix étaient réguliers
donc on a dû absorber nous-mêmes ce choc
de l'inflation sur 2022 et
et probablement
et sur 2023 également donc là aussi il y
a une question je dirais en termes de
régulation
comment faire pour que parfois certaines
entreprises puissent même si c'est
transitoire bénéficier d'augmentation de
prix pour pouvoir
absorber le choc de l'inflation
juste madame Imbert excusez-moi je vois
que j'ai pas répondu à votre question
sur la différenciation de la
tarification en fonction des formes
pharmaceutiques notre prix de revient ce
que je vous disais en fait il est
calculé matière première matériau de
conditionnement et les coûts de
conversion donc bien évidemment quand on
fait de l'effervescence on utilise des
excipients différents donc ça peut
coûter plus cher donc effectivement
nous adapter des prix en fonction de la
forme galénique et je dirais de la
plus-value à portée par la forme
galénique parce que on sait que
l'effervescence c'est une rapidité
d'action qui est quand même
importantes et démontrer cliniquement
ça aurait du sens bien évidemment sur
sur les prix
pour la question monsieur Moga donc oui
bah sur tout ce qui est nos
collaborateurs le bien-être la qualité
de vie chez nous je pense que ça c'est
un nos axes stratégiques hyper important
et sur votre question sur la
communication
alors il est vrai que pendant pendant la
crise qu'on a connu
je dirais que la communication a été
assez intensive pour UPSA et cette prise
de parole en fait
elle a été rendue possible parce qu'on a
eu évidemment beaucoup de sollicitations
de médias mais qu'on était aussi dans
une démarche de proactivité et notamment
on a diffusé deux communiqués de presse
pour expliquer notre situation et en
fait si vous voulez aussi rassurer les
Français pour éviter un effet voilà de
de stockage qui aurait été inappropriés
de médicaments dans les armoires à
pharmacie et une sorte de le syndrome
voilà une peur qui serait infondée donc
pour nous on voulait vraiment faire de
la pédagogie en disant mais voilà nous
on est là on n'a pas de problème on
n'a pas de problème d'approvisionnement
on n'a pas de rupture sur nos produits
on est capable de fournir le marché et
d'ailleurs on a été capable de le faire
si vous voulez en France mais moi qui
m'occupe aussi de tous les autres
marchés suisses Belgique etc on a aussi
été capable de fournir ses marchés et en
termes de communication on a aussi
donc dans dans ces pays-là communiquer
pour dire que il y aurait pas de rupture
de rupture dans ces dans tous ces pays
là et ça ça nous tenait vraiment à coeur
parce que pour nous c'est vraiment notre
mission première qui est de dire on se
doit de garantir un accès continue
à nos médicaments aux patients donc on
voulait le dire on voulait
expliquer expliquer aussi pourquoi
c'était possible et les conditions qui
faisaient que nous n'avions pas de
rupture
sur Dafalgan efferalgan donc oui
beaucoup de prise de parole beaucoup de
pédagogie aussi sur ce qu'un site
industriel comment ça fonctionne
voilà comment on peut le mobiliser et
comment nous on a réussi à le mobiliser
donc c'était une volonté aussi de
l'entreprise de s'ouvrir et d'être
extrêmement transparent dans son
discours transparente et humaine honnête
sincère donc et je vous ai dit aussi sur
la pédiatrie on a été très
très transparent disant nous on pourra
pas pallier les insuffisances qui qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui sur le marché de la
pédiatrie puisque on peut on a une ligne
de production des solutions buvables en
revanche on double notre production on
fait nos meilleures efforts et on
réoriente une partie de la production
enfin une partie qui était destinée à
l'export
en collaborant avec les autorités de
santé
donc sur après sur votre question sur la
question de la relocalisation est-ce que
c'est que de la relocalisation de
principe actifs ou bien la
relocalisation
de la fabrication je pense que ce qui
est important c'est de maintenir les
sites industriels aujourd'hui en France
qui fabrique des médicaments
je vous dirais nous voilà c'est 350
millions de boîtes par an
je pense qu'on a démontré qu'on était un
site qui avait une capacité de
production stratégique pour le pays donc
il faut en tout cas encourager ce
maintien des sites et après la vraie
question se pose effectivement au niveau
de la chimie et je souscris à ce que
vous dites c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
pas tout
réinternaliser en France c'est pas vu le
nombre de molécules en revanche faire le
travail qui je crois est fait
actuellement d'identifier les
médicaments qui ont un intérêt
industriel et sanitaire
me semble extrêmement important
justement pour pouvoir avoir des
priorités des priorités qui combinent
ces deux aspects à la fois sanitaire et
industriel pour pouvoir justement
imaginer des solutions de relocalisation
et je pense que si dans la chimie il
faut être très à innover donc il faut
aussi encourager le développement de
processus différents
parce qu'on innove aussi en chimie
et voilà de production à partir
peut-être d'autres composants
de ces principes actifs
merci merci c'est gentil de la parole à
la présidente j'aurais effectivement
deux trois questions complémentaires à
vous poser
alors je reviens sur sur le
contingentement j'ai bien compris que
vous aviez très bien travaillé avec la
NSM pour autant est-ce que c'est normal
qu'un contingentement soit imposé à
laboratoire qui n'est pas en rupture
d'approvisionnement et qui a cette
capacité à produire plus
contrairement à d'autres laboratoires
pour lequel effectivement il y avait un
réel contingentement parce qu'ils
arrivaient pas à produire ça reste une
question posée je moi je me la pose sur
le ce qui a une équité de traitement on
pourrait penser que celui qui était de
traitement mais d'un autre côté ça peut
être aussi pénalisant d'un laboratoire
plus qu'un autre mais je vais revenir
sur la clause de sauvegarde vous nous
avez dit que la clause de sauvegarde la
fameuse clause m avait été multipliée
par 10 est-ce que vous alors si vous
n'avez pas les éléments là je ne vous en
voudrais pas mais si vous pouvez nous
les communiquer ça m'intéresserait en
combien d'années
cette clause a été multipliée par 10
depuis qu'elle a été mise en place c'est
une mise en place assez récente je me
souviens pas de l'année ne m'en veuillez
pas mais je voilà c'est en combien
d'années elle a été multipliée par 10
quelle est la part en volume et en
pourcentage de votre chiffre d'affaires
sur le marché français
quel est en volume et en pourcentage
votre part de marché dans l'Union
européenne hors France et quel a été
l'évolution de de de vos ventes depuis
la mise en place de la clause de
sauvegarde en clair vous êtes pénalisé
par une fiscalité sur votre chiffre
d'affaires
des médicaments vendus sur le territoire
national est-ce que cette fiscalité
pénalise l'approvisionnement du marché
français
juste une seule petite question parce
que le tour a été fait vous venez
d'évoquer
la nécessité d'innovation en chimie et
je voulais savoir quand ils étaient en
qualité la part de recherche de
développement dans votre entreprise
est-ce que vous avez de la recherche en
chimie ou est-ce que vous comptez sur
ces 15 justement et l'accord que vous
avez passé avec les chimistes de ces 15
pour
arriver à avoir une production
différente sur le chimique mais quel est
votre part de R&D là dedans
Madame la Directrice je vous remercie
Laurence merci donc moi j'avais posé une
question tout à l'heure sur votre
présence au niveau de des lobby
européens comment quel est votre
position par rapport à vos concurrents
et je me semble pas avoir eu de
d'informations
en ce qui concerne les parts de vente à
l'étranger dont on vient de parler ma
collègue là ce serait très intéressant
aussi de les avoir non seulement
pourcentage mais en chiffres d'affaires
par produit et par pays pour avoir une
idée des des quantités merci
on reste dans le cadre de la pénurie de
médicaments
voilà je vous laisse répondre très bien
alors pour pour la première question sur
le contingentement je comprends tout à
fait que vous posiez la question
sur l'équité de traitement
après voilà nous on a aussi on est une
entreprise responsable et on se conforme
aux décisions des autorités de santé
donc on n'a pas à les commenter elles
sont ce qu'elles sont nous on a discuté
en amont avec la production de notre de
nos chiffres
de nos stocks qui étaient largement
suffisants après il y a un arbitrage qui
est fait et on s'y conforme
sur la clause de sauvegarde en fait ce
que je vous disais c'est depuis le
déclenchement de cette clause en fait
donc c'est en deux en trois ans cette
clause est multipliée par 10 donc c'est
quand même
non non c'est 2019 si je compare sur
2020 à 2022 en fait donc
on est vraiment parce qu'avant la clause
ne s'est pas déclenchée donc la
confiance
en fait vous avez raison elle a été
décidé on vient de vérifier en 2012 en
fait la clause existe depuis 1999 en
fait la contribution la clause de
sauvegarde c'est un mécanisme très
particulier qui existe depuis 1999 mais
effectivement qui ne s'est pas déclenché
mais là comme il y a une croissance
importante du marché
compte tenu aussi on ne peut que s'en
réjouir des médicaments innovants
l'enveloppe qui est votée par le
parlement des 24 milliards 5 n'est pas
suffisante pour absorber cette
innovation donc comme elle est dépassée
cette enveloppe qui a forcément du coup
une mutualisation donc en fait ce qu'il
voudrait faire aussi sur cette clause
c'est revoir le montant voté
annuellement par au Parlement pour les
dépenses de médicaments et d'essayer d'y
intégrer cette formidable dynamique de
l'innovation je pense que ce serait
quelque chose qui éviterait aussi de
pénaliser l'ensemble des laboratoires
sur la question du du chimiste et la
part de rechercher développement quand
une fois nous notre métier c'est la
pharmacie donc on fait vraiment voilà de
la fabrication et conditionnement de
médicaments après sur la question des
principes actifs oui enfin on encourage
vivement nos fournisseurs principes
actifs à être dans une logique de
recherche de développement et d'ailleurs
enfin aussi d'envisager des processus
qui soient d'un point de vue
environnemental
bien meilleur enfin donc on a aussi des
chartes précises sur sur ces exigences
là donc je dirais que la balle est dans
le camp des chemises sur sur la
recherche et développement
sur la dernière question sur
alors oui pour vous donner tous les
chiffres moi j'ai aucun problème à vous
donner tous nos chiffres la répartition
entre la France et l'export ce que je
vous disais on fait à peu près 436
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
donc
350 millions de boîtes
43% des volumes qui partent à l'export
et je pourrais vous donner je vais pas
vous égrener là précisément en fonction
des zones etc mais au niveau de l'export
voilà c'est à peu près 50 sur le chiffre
d'affaires donc on est voilà 230
millions sur la France et 210 millions
sur l'export donc
donc voilà donc pour nous l'export est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
aussi pour le modèle économique
sur le la question européenne oui enfin
en fait nous ipsa si vous voulez on a
une politique
de présence bien sûr et surtout de
co-construction donc on travaille avec
l'ensemble de l'écosystème
institutionnel et politique donc tout
d'abord parce qu'on est très transparent
sur ce qu'on fait on dit ce qu'on fait
on communique aussi sur nos engagements
et on prouve qu'on a réalisé les
engagements qu'on avait pris et donc on
travaille beaucoup avec l'ensemble des
partis prenantes pour nous c'est aussi
dans notre ADN de se dire c'est cette
co-construction qui est utile on le fait
à l'échelle du département du
Lot-et-Garonne on le fait à l'échelle de
la région on le fait à l'échelle
nationale et bien sûr européenne
également donc
et on essaie de donner de la visibilité
à nos actions
et de porter nos positions donc
mais encore une fois on reste une
entreprise de taille intermédiaire
dans le paysage pharmaceutique
voilà
vous avez remarqué ça nous fait beaucoup
réagir tout ce que vous dites nous
allons pousser en avant les
investigations
sur un certain nombre de sujets
notamment la cause de sauvegarde je
pense qu'il faut qu'on la regarde avec
une attention
renforcée clairement
donc voilà et on voit bien que le sujet
innovation dans le dépassement de de
l'enveloppe médicament tel que prévu par
le PLFSS peut peser d'un poids je veux
dire important en fonction de
l'innovation qui sort d'une année sur
l'autre aussi et puis de et puis de
l'intérêt c'est dire plus c'est
intéressant plus il y a de prescription
donc plus il y a de remboursement
derrière donc voilà donc tous ces sujets
là à un moment où on est en pleine
révolution j'allais dire
biotechnologique et bio biologique
dans la des thérapies il faut qu'on
regarde ça parce qu'évidemment ce sont
surtout les médicaments matures qui
proposent qui qui
qui sont en situation de pénurie et pour
le coup leur service médicalement rendu
pour un très grand nombre est
incontestable si je peux me permettre
d'ajouter très rapidement une dernière
chose c'est que notre engagement dans le
projet de relocalisation il s'est fait
en contrepartie d'un moratoire sur les
prix puisque en fait juste avant le
covid en 2019 il était question d'avoir
une baisse de prix sur nos médicaments
donc Dafalgan et feralgan et également
les concurrents et que finalement la
crise covid révélant les vulnérabilités
que l'on connaît
cette baisse de prix elle a été gelée et
en contrepartie et bien il y a eu cette
cette volonté de s'engager dans le
projet de relocalisation donc on
bénéficie d'un moratoire sur les prix
jusqu'à fin 2024
mais voyez bien que il y a une question
qui se pose sur 2025 puisque si on veut
pouvoir
être dans des conditions économiques
viables
il est bien évident que voilà il faut
réfléchir à la stabilité de prix
au-delà de 2024 voir à une hausse de
prix sur des médicaments comme comme le
paracétamol il y a une vraie question
qui se pose on a vraiment innové je
dirais d'un point de vue administratif
donc ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'extrêmement assalué puisqu'on a gelé
une baisse de prix en contrepartie d'un
engagement dans un projet pour la
reconquête industrielle tout à fait
très bien merci beaucoup
merci Madame la président